I'm joined by three other gamers to play
the VIP anthem demo we are from
literally all over the globe but we have
to play together as a team
if you don't rely on your team you will
probably fail at the game
watch me do that this could be fun
I am very excited to see how this turns
out
[Music]
this is gonna be interesting I want to
jump into the game
okay guys last time we managed to save
Matt just so we're pretty happy yeah I'm
happy I don't know about you but I'm
happy I do care about level 12 but yeah
so now we are level 12 so we going to be
able to switch the Jevens
yeah let's go for it we deserve this I
am really really liking the design of
the of the storm he looks like I kind of
don't really want to customize him too
much but you know I guess I'm gonna have
to I'm gonna go for a very some golden
just I'm gonna get real real nasty with
this I'm excited about this I can tell
you're getting exciting and nasty the
same thing I'm looking forward to a very
shiny outfit here shiny chrome so I'm
going for a pretty garish all shiny look
I like a cap I figure that my big tactic
now is gonna get caught in the glint of
the Sun and blind my enemies I figured I
was gonna work under percent but just in
case you still I kind of like I like to
have fun but I'm also here to party
certifier not sure what that means
please very similar vibe to your last
vibe that's a good strategy I mean the
enemy's gonna walk away what a fight you
good good just keep giving points well
I'm more in rare that they never make
sure you've got what you need red is
blood and blood
thank you I just want to look good oh
yeah I want you to know me pretty I'm
just taking a look at some of the other
types of outfit that we can actually
wear not just the paint that the the
physical you know items as well yeah a
church brand-new helmet going on right
here
you got a new helmet I do and it's on
and it looks good
I got a few details but I have a new
brand new helmet if you go unlock you
might just have enough coins to buy Oh
where's that was almost if you go to a
go to arms chest helmet anything yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah consider it have a head
oh yes oh this is so so I'm gonna take
this yeah oh yes release can we guys you
know switch money very big boy I'm a
very I'm a big thing boy and a nasty one
oh look at all look at my big legs
they're huge Wow yeah just stay behind
him I won't see the enemy from behind
him is huge is just oh man
[Laughter]
so my goal is the storm and I think I
get like a lot of elemental attacks with
a storm so basically I'm gonna hang back
and just freeze everyone to death good
or burn them one of the other lady base
and we send the max have crushed him
yes sorry I'll just I'm gonna run in
there like a like a big silly boy and
just make a mess of things
off the floor and you can dance with
them guys I can buy a guitar okay you
can you can buy you can buy a victory
pose it's great we only have one victory
pose and it's Flair's it's it's only
Flair's and I don't want to hear
anything about any others I've bought
just I just bought a guitar so
I look so cool I'm emote algún buy
emotes I'm gonna buy this one look at
this one's pretty cool wait wait look
tell it to the hand man that's that's I
have a strange culture here I like that
that's epic
ah I have just ruined the style guide
for this game I love it oh Jesus he
looks like another game he doesn't fit
in too thin to the environment it looks
like something like from the box art of
a game that came out in 1993 Oldman
Riddler
yeah the interiors not red though no
guys ready I am ready let's do it
[Music]
alright should we just meet up here
where you're not in the restricted area
[Applause]
this way oh all right
yes get up here yeah coming sorry I was
traumatized but this
hey guys I got to show you my new emote
I'm sorry yeah look all right I love
that email look this one no no sorry
sorry this one no okay let's go alrighty
I am really digging these outfits by the
way it's dangerous we looked awesome
let's stand that order here pose
yeah all right which way are we looking
to the front of the cave all right to
the cave
yeah right okay get in group photo I
[Applause]
think I have my eyes closed I'm sorry
got a great game I am already loving
this new javelin oh wait that turrets
yeah watch out for the oh all right fine
oh it's mine oh oh oh oh company Oh what
is it I got a combination level of us
plus the right button you have this
guy's I think so I have one yeah I think
I scream and I make everyone happy just
like Kim that I don't know all right
should we uh let's go to our first
objective supposed to go
we got here Oh somebody hanging out okay
so this looks like it's gonna be a bit
of a serious firefight we've got a lot
of turrets over here how do we want to
take this one on wait a second let me uh
what is going on here sorry I have a lot
of different gears
watch out for those mines okay I'm gonna
see if I can use some freezing tech go
up some these turrets got this amazing
gun with remember eco I love this night
oh that's gone sniper
yep that works really really well okay
yeah that's good here's this thing like
my my new javelin allowing me to
basically hover in the air and ages like
you just brain damage down from the sky
that's good a big beat we got to kill
this flame because enemies keep coming
I got a shield bash now that's fun I
want to see what my old I guess we're
about to find out oh yes never apologize
for overconfidence okay we are a team of
idiots sometimes we do the wrong thing
out of it I am somehow still in the sky
the enemy so there is a Trotter oh yes
so I can completely freeze people from
time to time as well so hopefully if
there's anyone who becomes a real
problem we can
like we should probably work together on
that maybe have a grenade launcher
I've iced this guy in the middle there
we go okay let's do some more that this
crystal thing yeah oh yeah destroyed
easily break it no no no the detectors
are the the ones from you didn't lead
from the tutorial the the shiny thing
okay there should be floating around so
I've got two of them here and I'm gonna
bring them to this thing and you can
come free of them okay let's just go
back there look like wait yeah like it
oh yeah the wonder okay so just follow
oh you're a little green radar Drive you
see them just pick up some three words
yeah so these things are called echoes
okay whoa whoa whoa sorry sir
turret I'm dead what where are you oh
did you go oh you went all the way over
there
see we got four out of eight out of
eight echoes - yeah if you get them all
okay max I'm coming - you don't come
here is nothing but death thank you so
much yeah sure
Tara dastan great and here's an echo
oh all right collecting echoes is
proving to be a really really dangerous
business there are
[Music]
I'm doing where are you all right I'm on
the way I haven't used my oh yeah baring
already got a different health play oh
oh I didn't get you up oh you think I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming
we're down together ultra yeah that's
that's a bit romantic oh it is at least
we're holding hands in our death okay
one each ah you know funny yeah yeah I
got it ego thank you very much I see
those guys yeah he is here I have a
shield oh yeah trying to get a wall up
around us
all right oh yeah I got it coach okay oh
wait 600 all right big guys frozen he's
frozen go for him all right he's back
I can't freeze him for long no professor
we might have to stick a little bit more
together for us yeah that's right crazy
guy yeah I got him hey nice okay we
might actually have a team thing going
on here nice I'm on my way up here we're
good we're good
I also have the shield dude dude
yes okay I'm a little bit of help there
it's back oh they track in the sky who
it is is it
say difficult okay Oh fire okay they got
a lot of fire come from the ground I'm
gonna try and freeze up some guys
leaving okay all right so where where
are you guys I'm gonna oh wait you're
still fighting this enforcer up here
he's an oh there's another big guy okay
any big guys give me give me a target
and I'll try and freeze one of them okay
ii just have to retreat is chase i got
there two of them should we just just
deliver the echos yes
maybe there's a frozen guy here by
eating it okay take him out nice nice
one nice team in place
alright he's frozen again I'm gonna hit
him I'll meet you guys I'm doing very
bad
all right reason one more time oh he's
down that was a nice guy that was it
that's how we're gonna do this or arrest
them
slow and steady slow and steady kills
bad guys yes if you guys won't need so
much [ __ ] shield in and medic all right
we got another big guy coming in here
all right by the way we we still need to
collect the echos so we need to make
sure that we ask don't just fight we've
got a got a hunt well but I got the big
one
there we go okay
yes warren- is it is it further up
obviously it's down here on this ledge
oh you got it yeah I got it my radars
gone which makes me think yeah the tough
one echo with me so should we head back
to the thing yeah that's good all right
good work guys was was tense try and
clear out spine feels all right
superhero landing yeah
we're gonna open some kind of portal or
something and then probably never get in
another fight yeah hey nicely done okay
something dramatic look at the scars
we're putting eggs to the relish the
eggs will filter Bassett
who'd be using the rally to weaponize it
Oh acid eggs of course I delicious eggs
shoot all the eggs
yes it's just right all right well like
we've got a new market okay we'll come
back later
yeah the blue wait for me guys oh you
know what before I fly off to my team I
am going to recharge my flight game
how's everyone finding their new
chaplains I like yeah I picked up an
echo already enemies watch out guys
what's up the oh that's a turret that
turrets yeah watch out for the turrets
alright I'm gonna see if I can freeze
one Oh No instead they just shot me
okay so we did that thing we do again
where we ran all that American movie
Haley what do you mean we didn't learn
our lesson alright should we try and
take these out systematically then yeah
we've got shoes good almost freezing
nice reason adequate huh
which one alright so there's one turret
that's straight ahead of us I'm gonna
skip and get yeah wait a second there's
this one on our wait just one enemy yeah
oh he's down down that's me
you need something right by you nice I
don't have any more ammo I'm a bit I
don't know we should probably keep an
eye out for some okay nice okay I'm at
I'm hanging back for now just to here
that'll help us out a little bit okay I
go down wait this okay they're behind us
yeah all right
trying to see if I can out one of these
turrets down a little even a little bit
feel like they didn't do as much as I
was hoping
yes there we go there we go okay I took
different which one which one how did
they got all teammates which one it's a
it's okay I got a hey hey oh good stuff
I'm still one over there I'm gonna go
straight for it I'm gonna I'm gonna
follow genius see if I can offer some
support Oh oh good an echo
over here
okay we retreat yeah alright we retreat
it sounds just guys as a wreck now go
Mexican let's resume X and that's back
up and let's cut a new attack this song
come on getting my head south from a man
that's yeah
all right yeah let's retreat regroup a
little bit watching yeah mines and
they're everywhere
let's have a new strategy all right okay
guys we're a team so let's spin to the
two groups one good they go you can get
the D echoes and get a group just take
care of the enemies
all right so slow do you wanna do you
wanna join me in an echo hunt sounds
good now let's fit the court I'm in so
okay okay so this is where we need to
deliver them to so okay so you got to go
you guys good the echos I'm a genius
where are you oh yes nice oh I'm down
man okay wait wait a second oh okay so
we go way through that easy yeah that's
time to droop oh yeah we're gonna split
again oh that's the turret okay yeah all
right I got you
there we go oh great thank you
all right so cool place to dodge duck
dip dive and dodge
so three are delivered all right those
are two of those guys
or even bothering with the turrets oh I
found the light of them all but I got
hit really hard this it is difficult it
is difficult no go down down down down
okay try to just check the specs -
they're not good solid evading I can I
can take one of the turrets out where
it's Marissa turret because they're the
ultimate detective wait there's all
right we got five turn this on or choke
max just mixing you yeah soon ah sorry I
like how I'm the big heavy one and I'm
taking all the damage Oh Dutch Oh genius
you got him yeah yeah I'll take on that
annoying guy right there
okay Wow this is painful going down
again I'm telling ya wait us yeah so
like I mean I'm coming I'm gonna finish
this guy okay all right okay
scar hunter is actually a heel yes so my
I'm not gonna come down radar a lot of
people over yet so what I suggest
okay thank you
okay okay so we've got eight to the
twelve yeah but no more birds are
something you under on the radar yeah
okay maybe we got two maybe we got a
decent killing oh oh yeah you got it
let me heat it I'm gonna heat it let's
get out of here okay I got this name
should I this is uh this is risky this
is risky all right I'm gonna get up
trying to soon as I've cooled down I'm
gonna get up in the sky and see if I can
offer some yes okay support I got chill
I got an mo
are you guys doing I'm trying to take
out a turret here because it's proving
to be my undoing
which one tell me I'm going to try to
snipe it I'm good first night but it's
on the right-hand side ie it's down to
download yeah oh there's a big guy
where is he ways few ways right grab X Y
I'm probably on fire hello I'm coming I
think we're all coming wait max just
have to
yeah the oven get up thank you yeah okay
it's time for the mean machine so wait I
got the big guy minutes time freeze the
big guy
and again good yes oh yeah close way oh
nice
okay let's do this you guys I've got all
the echoes so the rest of the echoes are
locked in these cells so we need to open
them up and collect them right take
these guys back now before I get too
greedy
[ __ ] cells okay two more to go yeah
gottoms uh just one minute one
to
okay so better go oh yeah okay you got
it yep got him I'd say these two one
that's it all right that's a lute that's
a loot chest blue chest yeah shooting
okay good job guys
yeah hmm what are we going to fight in
this room oh look up I think it might be
this guy oh no oh I do not like him
oh that's a that's a very eggy Saeki
thing that is definitely a Saeki eggy
bug
[Music]